I welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
I'm Darrin Smith in for Rich Eisen here
this afternoon and again thanks to the
entire crew here at the Rich Eisen show
for making me feel at home holding my
hand throughout this process as i and
shawn merriman who's sitting down with
us who is a San Diego charger who was a
Buffalo Bill Shawne Merriman came right
in here and we go way back lights out
you came right in here barking and
talking about my vest and my shirt which
I know you're gonna wear me out about
since we have a little bit of history
but cannot say enough about the
outstanding crew here on the Rich Eisen
show for all they've done the excellence
that they prepare themselves with each
and every day but Shawne Merriman
three-time NFL Pro Bowler lights out
extreme fighting on Twitter and very
active on social media at Shawne
Merriman that's sha WN e Shawne Merriman
on instagram with the same name good to
see you good to see you too so get it
let's get it out of the way you've been
this you've been given some marching
orders here to wear me out about the
vest about the shirt about the hair what
what Marty right our friend from mighty
290 Marty it makes you I give you some
crap about that vest personally I
thought it was I liked it it was okay
but then she told me about it and had me
look into a little bit more news it's
it's a little fashion but it's fine it
works for you and I got no complaints
law of fashion so what you're saying
here somebody's a little bit younger
here this is in between you want to go
to the club but you got a mean first
like I don't I don't know to look people
go but it works it's okay at one time
there's a racetrack in San Diego Del Mar
yep and one time you came on the show
there and you were critiquing my
wardrobe that day and I was yes and I
will tell you actually that has bothered
me all the way up into this doorway
because listen dude I'm not some
fashionista like you I am NOT some
big-time star who had this NFL career
who's an entrepreneur but yeah you you
you you right this is what Merriman did
he rubbed the materials like saying yeah
and he rubbed the materials like the
nice jacket no joke that's all he said I
was reduced you never knew this I was
reducing like
well I guess I'm not living up to Shawn
I gotta watch what I do next time then
if I know I'm bothering people that way
that wasn't my intention just to give
you a little crap yes it works Lee I'm
carrying this emotional oh wow Wow how
many years later well it is good to see
you good to see you too and it is always
good I have always said this too it's
funny because you and I we do have
history you go back to the time that you
were drafted by the Chargers you were
the 12th over pick overall pick in the
2005 draft and I will tell you years and
years and years on the radio in San
Diego which you almost got involved with
which we'll get to in a second yeah we
spent a lot of time on Shawne Merriman
and we always knew that Shawne Merriman
it's funny at the time we said Shawne
Merriman is he focused on football right
and it was a perceived negative now
today here you are you've got all these
business ventures going on and and good
for you good for you thank you in that
foresight it I appreciate in you know
that well you talk about bothered right
that bothered me back then um because I
did I did anyone ever tell you I was
always the first one in a weight room
you know last one to leave stayed after
practice constantly working on my pass
for us moves and coaches and took really
good care of my body for the outside of
the times I was injured and then when I
came out I was like man you know I'm had
a vision back then to build something
and you know lights out to me was bigger
than one person it was a brand it was
now a MMA league it was way bigger than
then I was not was kind of like this
driving force to it but I also kind of
got a bad rap because it was kind of a
persona and a brand and it was kind of
this demon Linga that I wasn't focused
on football and it was unfair and you
know I just felt like I was 10 or 15
years ahead of my time I think I was I
was just ahead of my time and I had a
vision and it wasn't really understood
back then and I think that most people
see what their vision is now yeah you
were unique in that regard because again
I think now we sort of say hey look good
for merriment for having a plan after
football see we can't always have it
both ways lights we're you know you have
your post playing career and you have a
vision for what it is that you want to
do and then go story after story after
story about players who find themselves
in unsafe you know bad situations you
know
so to your credit I don't think we
realize that at the time and now it's
pretty much commonplace maybe more in
the NBA than in the NFL still feels like
it's a little restrictive in the NFL
that you guys can have some personality
but but now more than ever players are
realizing they are a brand and that's a
pretty important part of who they are no
question about it and you know I look at
the charges team today and you got guys
like Melvin Ingram you know has rap
albums which is pretty you know pretty
damn good you know I've seen Keenan
Allen the other day singing on you know
he has a great voice and these guys who
are entrepreneurs outside the game and
you know you'd rather have guys doing
that than doing something they're not
supposed to and for me then it was
perceived more as I wasn't focused on
what I wanted to do and I was really
focused I just instead of going to spend
my time elsewhere I was building
something and it just was totally
perceived the opposite way right and
Shawne Merriman joining us here on the
Rich Eisen show on Darren Smith I seem
to remember one correct me if I'm wrong
here I might have a detail wrong but
it's LA San Diego geographically about a
hundred and ten hundred twenty miles
apart what's in there what year was that
where you would weren't you flying out
on Mondays so Tuesday the traditional
off day yeah but you would get on an
airplane and you'd fly up to LA right
yeah what was a yes so it was the it was
actually I was hurt um I think it was a
year that I was hurt and I did the show
with Jay Glazer and Eddie George I think
was pro football preview of something
like that I was actually the first
athlete that was playing at the same
time we'll also had a show and I've
never forget a Jay Smith that came out
that article general manager and came
out with that article that I wasn't
focused in this but I was I was injured
I was hurt it was the whole eight-year
and I was like what am I gonna do I'm
gonna rehab and have all this time
during the day so I actually ended up
doing that show and that's that's when
all that stuff has started around and
about you know just I wasn't focused on
playing football and I'm like man if you
only knew how much time and work that I
put into my craft it's just that you
only have a certain amount of time
during the day to be football related I
Oh at the time for me it was injury and
I heard you before I came out a little
bit talking about um you know Kevin
Durant's injury and some of these
injuries going around and these injuries
I've dealt with but you you know you do
these things for a couple hours a day
and then what and for me it was
to be in TV I wanted to do you know
broadcast and I wanted to do other
things and that was kind of like my my
leeway into it how old were you though
you got drafted you were 20 years old
yeah 2005 how old were you when you said
Shawne Merriman is gonna be more than
just a football player did that happen
during your career or did you enter the
league with that - uh 16 so 16 years old
16 years old yeah that's when I got the
nickname lights out and um I got that I
begged my mother to get let me get the
lights out tattoo on my right forearm I
had this I this vision back then that I
wanted this this is what I wanted to do
and I was actually would have some of my
Pell grant money when I was at the
University of Maryland I was selling
lights out close on campus and was
giving it to my teammates and suddenly
this was something I wanted to do back
then and it's kind of just coming around
now you know be always here the the
singing it takes 10 years to be an
overnight success right my case it was
like 13 or 14 but however long you not
took the time and it's something I had a
vision of doing and it's coming around
is that something do you preach that a
lot to younger players whether it's high
school college just getting into the
pros it's that's something you preach
say hey have a plan here they're gonna
try to keep it just singularly focused
on this make sure you you know you're
first and first and foremost you have to
be focused on your job and like your
passion that was to play football in but
it's only a certain amount of time
during the day and you can you know do
many things and and you want to make
sure you're doing the right things to
benefit your future when you're done
um and I knew I wanted to get to radio
and I want to talk a little bit about
even about mighty 1090 and you know me
trying to get involved with them in
business and what's not long ago I was
business man you're not a former
football player your business and I kind
of always been I was kind of just
trapped in his football body was you
know that really just love flying around
the field and being reckless and
relentless out there and playing the
game the way it was supposed to be
played for four quarters how long did
you want to play if injuries hadn't
forced out of the game how long would
cheers you had you said it's gonna be
because I knew the way I played the game
it was it was no way to physically he'd
keep going out there um and banging your
body up you know if you if you play ten
years that's a long long time in in that
game okay now I need to set this up real
quickly and just for anybody who's
tuning in here from San Diego and we'll
make it quick but
you mentioned talking about buying a
radio station shawn merriman since he
has played has been a TV personality
he's involved in lights out extreme
fighting which we're going to talk about
here momentarily
you have clothing break you're involved
in a lot of different things yeah you
mentioned the radio station so for 16
years I worked at a radio station in San
Diego Southern California called the
mighty 1090 mighty 1090 were you
actually going to buy this radio station
and become a media mogul Shawn Merriman
yes you were
yeah what stopped you uh it was just a
lot of things didn't fall in place um I
wish that they reached out to me earlier
what could it came in and actually done
something I will still do it I was still
doing right now you know I felt bad for
Scott and beyond Martin the whole the
whole team down there because you know
you guys have long history and I San
Diego will always be home for me and
they reached out to me too late and it's
unfortunate because a lot of jobs and
people down there suffered from them not
doing the right thing and my thing is I
have a you know a different kind of
focus and a different kind of outreach
and and want to do things differently
and my tea tonight is such a big brand
in San Diego in the California the
California and jeno and I would love to
bring it back okay well I'd I like what
kind of boss would you be now I'm pretty
good been out crazy
speaking of lifestyle extreme fight we
cruise McCain is that the way you would
a squall old squabbles just set a cage
up right dead office and you can Duke it
out and settle all your differences like
that I like that that's the way he runs
his operation he is Shawne Merriman he's
a three-time Pro Bowler he's here to
talk about lights out extreme fighting
before we do these guys we were talking
a little bit about the Washington
[ __ ] situation between Haskins and
whether or not you should turn it over
to a rookie right away and I think the
right answer is probably it's case by
case
yeah it's case by case but you were part
of that when you came into the league
with Drew Brees who had been the
established quarterback he gets hurt and
you had rivers waiting there as well
generally speaking though do you have a
lien one way or the other about starting
a first round quarterback right out of
the gate or do you prefer to let Case
Keenum or
Kurt Warner or the like establish let
them learn a little bit from the guy
who's been around the block yeah I don't
like it I don't like first-year guys
start no and sometime they're rushed
because of their draft pick right you're
going to top five top ten or sometimes
even the first round they expect you to
get on the field right away but when I
came in as the positions different you
know I I had to use my athleticism in
just explosion off an edge you can
literally put me on a field lined me up
anywhere and I can go get a quarterback
I'll go one-on-one against a tight end
or offensive tackle
I believe throwing a guy in it too early
and he doesn't have success can possibly
ruin his entire career because what
happens is you know that's it's a
position that is very very emotional
it's you know the mental part of that
position can really is everything you
have I mean I talked about Phillip or
even Tom Brady I mean Tom I guarantee
Tom Brady couldn't throw up with 50 or
60 yards on a dime I guarantee you he
couldn't but the mentor his mentality
and how much he knows about the game and
his confidence allows him to keep going
out and doing what he's doing right now
you're gonna destroy that for a young
guy it's gonna linger for the rest of
his career and I'm looking at see what's
gonna happen out in Miami it's no one
got put in a situation the team was bad
all the way around and if he can bounce
back mentally
he'll be fine well tell me how about the
number one overall pick yeah Marisa I
mean there's up and down it goes but I
do think though time each case problem
yeah some guys is just ready I mean it
when Andrew Luck came in he was a guy
that you could just stroll on the field
and he's gonna go out and be ready to
play right well let's talk a little bit
about lights out extreme fighting
another one of Shawn Merriman's great
adventures here we mentioned a little
bit we talked about what the concept is
here debut event May 11th it sold out
second event coming up on July 6th so
right at the end of a nice holiday
weekend here burr bar Burbank Marriott
Event Center here in Los Angeles tell us
a little bit about what you got going up
yeah so it's our second one out lights
out extreme fighting out here right here
Burbank Marriott eventually you can get
your tickets at lights out except calm
you know the whole thing is I've been
around this sport for 14 years right I
mean I was training though my all
seasons I was start training with Jay
Glazer in between 2005 and 2006 Randy
Couture and you know just some of the
best fighters out there and I wanted to
really just work on my hand-eye
coordination my leverage and just help
me during a football whoa I ended up
kind of falling in love for the sport
when I retired you know I knew that I
was gonna be in the sport I didn't know
how I actually thought I was gonna be
fighting you know I had a couple
opportunities um but the right
opportunity didn't come about I'm
shocked by the way that you never did
well I would have bet good money it was
this close to two times it was this
close to me fighting with Bellator um
they never officially came to me with
the contract it was did I like and then
it was a bare-knuckle which that
promotion end up crumbling but the whole
time did you know I knew that this
lights out lights out extreme fighting
was gonna be launched um the thing is
with us we have athletes transitioning
from other sports right you know Chris
McCain we just talked about for my
charge in Miami Dolph and I think he
played with the Saints in college for a
little bit too Roy white played in NBA
playing with the big three right now
he's another guy that all could
eventually come over we would talk the
other day I'll be meet with him next
week when he's done with the big three
so we'll have we got a couple NHL guys
so yeah well those guys thank you so
that's big that's where the smart money
is being bat right brockman you put them
on the NHL guys but how trained are
these guys I mean that they literally
walking off a football field or get
taking their skates off and and jumping
into the ring or some of these guys
trained well getting into yeah some of
these guys are walking in there raw
athletes just like I was right you don't
you're not walking in with two two left
feet and you can't you don't have any
coordination so they're athletes walking
in now they're picking up on it getting
in training camps you know wherever they
are in the country Chris McCain's down
here when the Antonio McKee down south
royce y is the same he's down south in
irvine so when these guys come in you
get with the right trainer and you take
that sheer athleticism they have from
this sport and transfer it over to now
learning the technical side of combat
sports in MMA you can be dangerous so
real quick which which former teammate
would you want to get into the ring with
former teammate yeah no none really none
of my team could we were all boys man we
had you know we had a
a group of guys okay we'll expand it
which which NFL player that you can that
you played against that you competed
against would you want to get into the
ring with I'm thinking now I don't never
had really enemies what I did through
those four quarters was strictly
business I had to go out and do whatever
it was it was all business I don't I
don't think I came across a guy who I
just didn't like um they may they might
have been a character somebody I didn't
like during the game but I got to know
them off the field and I never never had
that kind of problem so maybe you go
with the Titans yeah maybe one of those
Jeff Fisher coach but even with those
guys you know we've we actually talked
I've had talks with now with Jeff Fisher
but with this the center Kevin muwaiya
you know we something coming out pretty
soon I think here in Sports Illustrated
about that whole thing there really
would not do I don't think people knew
about the idea that there was a bounty
on you yeah yeah well there's a bounty
or not get me something bad happen in it
my career changed because of it so why I
got a chance to kind of square it off
and shake hands with Kevin Moore why and
it's a pretty good article all right are
you done with me
are you done wearing me out any other
grievance from 14 years ago 13 years ago
that's it just lights out extreme
fighting I want everybody if you're in
town July 4th weekend come it's in
Burbank Marriott get your tickets at
lights out exf dot-com Sean's also the
CEO the light south ethic in lifestyle
apparel brand go to lights out brand.com
it's good to see you good to see you
back mighty 290 let's do it I think you
have a lot of people who are listening
in San Diego in Southern California who
is go about that Shawn it is good to see
you too very much for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app